[Music]  beware of false prophets who come to you  in sheep's clothing but inwardly they  are ravening wolves jesus is the  shepherd who protects you from those  wolves and I am his dog the sheepdog  that get the Lambs back on track when  they stray off the path and some of you  have strayed haven't you  are you beautiful Reverend says he's  here to take you back where he came from  I know you're there  and I know you can hear me you may have  nothing wrong with your ears do you know  why I'm here  I'm here to punish you why do you let  him do this it's a sin  I love him  even order it is lustre  ain't never gonna stop is he I seen your  mother she's the kind of person that  turns the other cheek be like her  never leave your loved ones alone you  should know that by now  [Music]  you